and that's gonna be the big concern it's
not about LeBron James and Anthony Davis
as a tandem as we see the pod coming off
the pick the roll make it a place it's
about both of those guys remaining
hounds with the rebound 17th year for
LeBron Hill turned 35 at the end of the
summer he just bullies press all the way
to the basket that time that's a tough
line
Kuzma still out with an ankle injury
here's Davis the lock to the game roll
with bond James they play him as a
scorer willingly gives up the rock and
the confined shooters on the floor he's
a bright spot early on this season for
them free seasoning
what pass by James and the Slam by Davis
and finds shooters on the floor he's a
bright spot early on this season for
them preseason
pass by James and the Slam by Davis from
Larry Bird instability this guy is top
10 all-time they climb into cha when
it's all set and then he's gonna be top
five all-time his body of work is
ability to see the floor had as much
time off as he did to overcome that
injury Wow how about that take a stand
for the followed stink but again just an
amazing look another dunk Dominic got
that he's going to be able to truly
cheer on gems 3 assists 2 points 6
points for Magee 5 for Davis to go with
4 rebounds another terrific look by
LeBron to a cutting Avery Bradley Ron
James already as the Lakers a big hit he
a Clippers home game and then the Lakers
will play their next three and official
home games against Utah Charlotte and
Memphis James had transaction with a
spin on Lee
defense sprinting back when he sees a
wall did you give them any lien on any
gap is a recipe for disaster
good night she can't be in the truck
five guys have to be sprint about a
three-second difference in the clocks
here's Davis shakes the defender spins
and I Freight dick Karissa
prior to that was the last to repeat his
MVP James actually did it twice how will
you fit white Howard the ability to make
a play dive to the hoop James being
defended by Eric Pascal rookie out of
Villanova James on the spin it up that's
eight Bella Braun it's a couple of
minutes he's decided to play a little
one-on-one and be more aggressive and
results James going right back to back
and down Pascal
and again tips the following getting the
friendly bounce that time picking and
choosing when he's gonna look to make
plays and when he's gonna carry the team
offense 23 okay give it up at some point
you got to take the trip to the DMV I
didn't have monitor my three year in
college they got Davis Howard and James
all on the floor together here with
green and caldwell-pope LeBron is gonna
take the deep three and his first trip
will trial tonight he's successful coach
hoop it around
the disciple of the great Rick Pitino
he's more than qualified to do the job
James
finish pissing it off the glass and
defense you give them an angle turns the
corner where's the help you help late
there's a price to pay gets all the way
to the cup for the easy layin
warriors open the regular season a week
from tomorrow against the Clippers at
the brand-new chase Center in San
Francisco
Harris McGee from Davis five assists for
Anthony Davis now he basically had
because he played for him and you guys
have worked together for 15 years with
Mike Breen on the finals it's dated a
story like half your life has been spent
Kenan Tandon that is blocked by Davis
they played by Anthony has it look out
he's on the ground again LeBron James
let's stop that he's a he's an
outstanding young player with an
incredible
and I love ways that right now we've
seen one LeBron James in the history of
this game the ability to rebound and
initiate the offense and make a play
pass pick James over the head with the
left hand in the corner as he's falling
out of bounds head Green pays it off
from three-point range only one guy
that's been LeBron James what a
spectacular play that's a small forward
playing the point guard position